[موسيقى]
اصوات اشكال البشر على شاشات التلفزه
والاجهزه الذكيه هي تحاكي الحقيقه وليست
الحقيقه ذاتها وهذا حالنا مع نجوم السماء
فمن النجوم من مات ولا وجود له وما زلنا
نشاهد ماضيها الان ومن النجوم من ولد
وموجود لكن لا نشاهده الان لان خبر ولادته
لم يصلنا حتى الان ليش لان النجوم تبعد
عنا بعدا سحيقا وهذه المسافات لا تقاس
بالكيلو مترات انما تقاس بالسنين الضوئيه
والسنه الضوئيه الواحده هي المسافه التي
يقطعها الضوء في سنه وهو يسير بسرعه 300
الف كيلو متر بثانيه ان مواقعها عظيمه فلا
اقسم بمواقع النجوم وانه لقسم لو تعلمون
عظيم
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فالمجموعه الشمسيه وافرادها من الزهره الى
نبت تقاس بالكيلو مترات فالشمس تبعد عنا
150 مليون كيلو متر وضوءها يصلنا بعد ثمان
دقائق تقريبا اما النجوم فلها حكايه
مغايره فاقرب نجم لنا يبعد عنا اربع سنوات
ونصف سنه ضوئيه وش يعني هالكلام هذا يعني
ان هذا النجم لو انفجر ما رايح ندريبه الا
بعد اربع سنوات ان يعتقر صغرا فربما مفخما
يبدو ضئيل شخصي للنظاري ان الكواكب في علو
محلها لا تراث صغارا وهي
غير صغاري
[موسيقى]